>>> BREAKING NEWS.
MOMENTS AGO, THE GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA ANNOUNCING THE
COVID-19 VACCINE WILL BE ADDED
TO THE STATE'S CURRENT LIST OF
IMMUNIZATIONS REQUIRED TO ATTEND
SCHOOL.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT K-12
SCHOOLS.
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW.
THIS REQUIREMENT WILL BEGIN THE
TERM FOLLOWING FULL FDA APPROVAL
FOR GRADES GROUPED AT K-6 AND
THEN 7-12.
RIGHT NOW, AS YOU KNOW, PFIZER'S
VACCINE FOR 12-15-YEAR-OLDS IS
STILL EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZED,
AND SO THIS WILL APPLY TO
STUDENTS AT BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SCHOOLS.
IT WILL BE SUBJECT TO EXEMPTIONS
FOR BOTH MEDICAL REASONS AND
PERSONAL BELIEFS, BUT THIS IS A
FIRST IN THE COUNTRY, AND IT
COMES ON THE HEELS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S RECALL ELECTION, A
RECALL THAT BEGAN OVER HIS
COVID-19 RESTRICTIONS SO LET'S
GET TO THE CALIFORNIA CAN HAVE
GAVIN NEWSOM WHO JOINS US NOW.
THANKS FOR MAKING TIME FOR US,
GOVERNOR.
THIS IS A BIG ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> WHY IS THIS THE RIGHT MOVE
RIGHT NOW?
>> YEAH.
I THINK WE'RE ALL JUST EXHAUSTED
BY THIS.
WE WANT TO GET THIS PANDEMIC
BEHIND US, AND WHILE WE'VE MADE
GREAT PROGRESS, CALIFORNIA 84%
OF CALIFORNIANS ELIGIBLE
RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE DOSE.
WE HAVE THE LOWEST CASE RATE IN
AMERICA.
IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH, AND WE
HAVE A COHORT 12-17 RIGHT NOW
WHERE ONLY 63.5% OF OUR KIDS
HAVE RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE DOSE
OF VACCINE, AND WE THINK THIS
WILL ACCELERATE OUR EFFORTS TO
GET THIS PANDEMIC BEHIND US.
>> YOU POINT OUT THOUGH
CALIFORNIA IS MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
COVID CASES ARE DECLINE RIGHT
NOW IN YOUR STATE.
ALMOST 70% OF ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS ARE FULLY
VACCINATED.
THAT, OF COURSE, IS 12 AND
OLDER.
84% HAVE HAD AT LEAST ONE DOSE
SO WHAT MAKES YOU THINK THAT THE
CURRENT STRATEGY ISN'T ENOUGH?
>> BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN HUMBLED
OVER THE LAST YEAR.
I MEAN, EVERY TIME WE TAKE OUR
EYE OFF THE BALL AND WE THINK
WE'VE GOT THIS OR MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT ISSUE OR CHALLENGE WE HAVE
A NEW MUTATION, A NEW VARIANT
THAT COMES OUT AND NEW VARIABLES
THAT COME OUT.
LOOK, I'M MINDFUL OF THE
SEASONALITY OF THIS AND WHILE
CALIFORNIA HAS WITHSTOOD THIS
LAST WAVE, WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE FALL AND INTO THE
SPRING OF NEXT YEAR, AND SO GOOD
ENOUGH NEVER IS WITH THIS
DISEASE, AND WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE
ARE STILL DYING.
700,000 AMERICANS.
WE KNOW THAT KIDS ARE BEING
INFECTED.
KIDS ARE ENDING UP IN OUR
HOSPITAL SYSTEM.
I HAVE FOUR YOUNG KIDS.
I CAN'T TAKE THIS ANYMORE.
I'M LIKE MOST PARENTS, WANT TO
GET THIS BEHIND US AND GET THIS
ECONOMY MOVING AGAIN AND MAKE
SURE OUR KIDS NEVER HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT GETTING A CALL
SAYING THEY CAN'T GO TO SCHOOL
THE NEXT DAY BECAUSE ONE OF THE
KIDS OR STAFF MEMBER TESTED
POSITIVE.
>> I HEAR YOU TO TWO YOUNG KIDS
WHO AREN'T ELIGIBLE TO BE
VACCINATED JUST YET, I'M FEELING
YOUR PAIN.
FIVE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICTS, YOU KNOW, HAVE BEEN
LEADING THE WAY, OUT FRONT
REQUIRING THE VACCINE.
JUST THIS WEEK SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT, WHICH IS THE
STATE'S SECOND LARGEST DISTRICTS
UNANIMOUSLY VOTED TO APPROVE A
VACCINE MANDATE THAT ALL
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS HAVE TO BE
VACCINATED AS WELL AS THE STAFF
IN THAT DISTRICT, BUT THERE WAS
OPPOSITION TO THIS.
NO SURPRISE, OF COURSE.
LET'S LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED AT A
RECENT COUNTY BOARD MEETING
THERE.
>> YOUR CHILDREN AND YOUR
CHILDREN'S CHILDREN WILL BE
SUBGY GATED, HOW MANY VACCINES
HAVE YOU HAD?
HAVE YOU BEEN A GOOD LITTLE
NAZI?
HAIL FAUCI, HAIL FAUCI, HAIL
FAUCI!
>> WHAT ARE YOU EXPECTING IN
TERMS OF THAT KIND OF, YOU KNOW,
REACTION POTENTIALLY OVER THIS
NEW STATEWIDE MANDATE?
>> LOOK, WE ARE MANDATE TEN
VACCINES.
IN SO MANY WAYS THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT --
ANNOUNCEMENT BUT PROBABLY THE
MOST PREDICTABLE ANNOUNCEMENT.
WE REQUIRE FOR MUMPS AND MEASLES
AND RUBELLA AND SO MANY OTHER
DISEASES.
WE REQUIRE VACCINATIONS AND YET
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
DISEASE THAT'S BECOME SO
POLARIZED AND SO DIVISIVE, AND
IT'S -- IT'S TRAGIC.
I MEAN, MY HEART GOES OUT TO THE
PEOPLE PROTESTING THAT THEY ARE
LED WITH SUCH FEAR AND
ANXIETIES, SUCH DISINFORMATION
AND MISINFORMATION, VERY
INTENTIONAL AND SOME JUST
NAIVELY RECEIVING IT.
SO, LOOK, WE HAVE TO REMIND
PEOPLE THAT THIS IS
WELL-ESTABLISHED TERRITORY FOR
OUR KIDS FOR DECADES AND
DECADES.
OUR KIDS AND PARENTS HAVE BEEN
BRINGING OUR KIDS INTO THE
DOCTORS OFFICE OR GETTING THEM
TO THE SCHOOL NURSE OR GETTING
THEM VACCINATED AND KEEPING THEM
HEALTH AND SAFE.
WE'RE JUST ADDING ONE ADDITIONAL
THING TO THE LIST SO THE REST US
CAN MOVE BEYOND THIS PANDEMIC
AND DISEASE AND GET THE ECONOMY
MOVING AND KEEP OUR KIDS BACK IN
PERSON FOR INSTRUCTION WHICH
EVERY PARENT, EVEN THOSE
PROTESTING WANT TO SEE.
>> BUT SO MANY PARENTS AND MAYBE
IT'S A MINORITY, BUT THERE'S
STILL ENOUGH OF THEM, AND THEY
ARE A LOUD MINORITY, WHO DON'T
EVEN WANT MASK MANDATES.
LAST MONTH AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLTEACHER NEAR SACRAMENTO
WAS HOSPITALIZED AFTER A PARENT
ALLEGEDLY ATTACKED THEM OVER
MASK MANDATES.
WHO ARE YOU EXPECTING WELL IF Y
SOMEONE, ATTACK ME.
I WAS THE FIRST GOVERNOR TO
REQUIRE MASKING FOR ALL OF OUR
PUNT SCHOOLS AND THE FIRST
GOVERNOR TO REQUIRE VACCINE
VERIFICATIONS OR TESTING AND IF
YOU WANT TOO GO AFTER SOMEONE,
GO AFTER ME.
DON'T GO AFTER THE INNOCENT
FOLKS TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
DAMN THING.
I MEAN THAT.
WE'RE BETTER THAN THAT.
OUR KIDS ARE WATCHING.
KIDS ARE WATCHING.
THE ADULTS AND THEY'RE MIRRORING
OUR BEHAVIOR, NOT WHAT WE SAY
BUT WHAT WE DO.
WE'RE BETTER THAN THIS.
YOU HAVE A PROBLEM, COME AFTER
ME.
STOP ATTACKING AND THEN
ANTAGONIZING THOSE ACROSS THE
STATE.
THEY DON'T DESERVE IT.
>> WHO HAS TO ENFORCE THIS?
>> WE HAVE RULES AN REGULATIONS
THAT ARE WELL ESTABLISHED FOR
VACCINES ALREADY.
IT IS THE SAME RULES, SAME
REGULATIONS, DISTRICT BY
DISTRICT.
CALIFORNIA IS THE LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN AMERICA, THOUSANDS
AND 25 DIFFERENT INDEPENDENT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND WELL
ESTABLISHED SCHOOLS PROCEDURES
AND FOR DATA COLLECTION BUT ALSO
AS IT RELATED TO STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS AND THERE IS RULES
FOR EMPLOYMENT, CONDITIONS OF
EMPLOYMENT, YOU HAVE THEM, I
HAVE THEM.
WELL ESTABLISHED.
THEY'RE CONSISTENT WITH WHAT IS
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS.
>> AND TO BE CLEAR, FOR OUR
VIEWERS IN CASE IT WASN'T CLEAR
EARLIER, THIS AT THIS POINT
WOULD APPLY TO PEOPLE 16 AND
OLDER BECAUSE THAT IS THE AGE
GROUP THAT HAS A FULLY APPROVED
VACCINE AT THIS POINT.
AND AS YOU POINT OUT, YOUNGER
PEOPLE AREN'T ELIGIBLE EVEN FOR
EMERGENCY USE YET.
IT IS POSSIBLE, HOWEVER, THAT
THE PFIZER VACCINE COULD BE
AUTHORIZED FOR YOUNGER CHILDREN
AGES 5 TO 11 IN THE COMING
WEEKS.
MEANWHILE, THERE IS A RECENT
POLL THAT FOUND LESS THAN A
THIRD OF PARENTS OF CHILDREN AND
IN THAT AGE RANGE PLAN TO GET
THEIR KIDS VACCINATED AS SOON AS
IT IS AVAILABLE.
I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE YOUNG
CHILDREN, YOU BROUGHT IT UP,
UNDER THE AGE OF 12.
DO YOU PLAN TO GET THEM
VACCINATED AS SOON AS THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE?
>> YEAH, AND I HAVE A
12-YEAR-OLD AND SOMEONE WHO JUST
TURNED 12 AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
GETTING VACCINATED.
WE ANTICIPATE AND NOT SURPRISING
THE FDA APPROVAL OF 12 TO
17-YEAR-OLDS, THAT IS THE FIRST
COHORT AND THE FIRST PHASE IN
WITH THE NEW RULES.
5 TO 11 WILL TAKE MORE TIME.
AND OVER THE COURSE OF TIME, YOU
SAW THIS, EVEN WITH THE 12 PLUS
COHORT, THOSE NUMBERS NOT
DISSIMILAR, THEY START TO BUILD
MORE TRUST AND CONFIDENCE AND
EVEN WITH THE POLLING NUMBERS 5
TO 11 THAT PARENTS WERE LOOKING
FORWARD TO FDA APPROVAL NOT JUST
THE EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION.
SO AS THIS GETS SOCIALIZED AND
AS WE LEAN MORE AND MORE STATES
DO WHAT CALIFORNIA IS DOING, I
THINK YOU'LL SEE THE NUMBERS AND
ANXIETY CHANGE AND IN CLOSING
THAT IS A BIG PART OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND FOLKS WITH
ANXIETY AND WHEN IT COMES TO THE
KIDS AND THE VACCINES THEIR KIDS
ARE ALREADY SAFELY TAKING AND
THIS IS ANOTHER OF THE MANY,
MANY DOSES OF VACCINES THAT ARE
EXPENDING THEIR LIVES AND
KEEPING OUR SOCIETY HEALTHY.
>> SO AS A PARENT YOU HAVE NO
CONCERNS OVER GETTING YOUR KIDS
VACCINATED AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
WHEN THEIR ELIGIBLE IN.
>> NO.
I HAVE CONCERN ABOUT MY KIDS
GOING TO SCHOOL AND GETTING SICK
AND GETTING OTHER KIDS SICK AND
THE BUS DRIVERS AND PARA
PROFESSIONALS GETTING SICK.
I HAVE CONCERN ABOUT OTHER
PARENTS MANIPULATING FACTS AND
CONCERNS AND I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
500,000 AMERICANS DYING AND OUR
ECONOMY IS NOT WHERE IT NEEDS TO
BE AND OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS
CONTINUE TO CLOSE BECAUSE WE
HAVE CLOSED OUR MINDS TO